and we start tonight with word that one  ccsd school is returning to virtual  learning thanks for joining us at six  i'm brian loftis i'm denise valdez  lamping elementary in henderson will  immediately transition to distance  learning because of the high number of  coveted 19 case cases at that campus now  the principle of lamping says online  classes will last at least two weeks and  then the district will re-evaluate their  individual situation there is no word on  how many students or staff may have  tested positive those who do not show  symptoms will be allowed to return to  face-to-face instruction on monday  august 30th